Start the year off right with a brunch that brings good luck.
Knowing a few New Year's Day traditions and superstitions will help you plan the perfect meal.
You will need: lucky flowers, pomegranate cocktails, lucky foods,...
...round or ring-shaped desserts and leftovers.
Step one: fill vases with flowers believed to bring good luck...
...magnolias, irises, peonies, lotuses, chrysanthemums, and plum blossoms.
Step two: Start with a cocktail that contains pomegranate juice.
Pomegranates are part of many New Year's Day menus in Mediterranean countries...
...because they represent abundance.
Step three: Include at least one of these foods at your New Year's Day brunch:...
...Cabbage, which represent money; lentils, which symbolize coins;...
...pork, because pigs represent progress and a rich life;...
...and long noodles, which signify a long life.
Avoid serving lobster and chicken; they represent setbacks and regrets.
Step four: Serve a Bundt cake or any ring-shaped sweet for dessert.
It ensures closure for the old year.
Some cultures hide a small trinket or coin in the cake they serve at New Year's Day brunch;...
...the person who finds it is destined for an especially fortunate year.
Step five: Leave a morsel or two on your plate;...
...it guarantees that your pantry will always be stocked in the coming year.
Did you know?
If the first person to cross your threshold in the New Year is a tall, dark, handsome man,...
...you're going to have a good year,...
...according to the Scottish superstition known as the first-footer.